aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un
nouveau smartphone nouveau smartphone
qui est nouveau sans être réellement
nouveau puisque je vous parle de ce
smartphone là c'est le honor ne fixe pas
si vous voyez bien trop modèle
professionnel vous ai déjà parlé du
honor ne fixe l'année dernière dans la
deuxième partie de 2010 9
je vous avais montré ce smartphone c'est
un smartphone milieu entrée de gamme qui
est vraiment correct et l'andorre a
présenté il ya très très peu de temps la
version professionnelle était déjà
disponible en asie mais pas chez nous on
va donc regarder quelle est la
différence entre le au nord de fixe et
le haut nord 9 x pro vers lequel
allaient il ya des différences vraiment
significatif est notable il faut savoir
que le au nord de fix pro est vendu au
prix auquel étaient vendus l'honneur 9x
côté a été présenté donc ce modèle c'est
celui là moi j'ai un dock est très sympa
gardez là il vous fait une espèce de x
très difficile à voir
on le voit le x mais par contre j'ai pas
si vous voyez il n'y a absolument pas de
capteur d'empreintes digitales
on va se faire un tour complet globale
pour voir quelles sont les différences
est-ce qu'il est fait pour vous oui ou
non toutes les choses qui sont
similaires avec l'honneur 9x fait pas le
détail ici je vous invite à aller voir
la vidéo du bonheur de fix qui va
s'afficher quelque part par là ils sont
dans la description également comme ça
ce qui va pour l'honneur de fixe va
également pour lui sauf les points de
différence que je vous énumérez dès
maintenant mais avant toute chose avant
de commencer on est toujours pendant la
période de confinement et je vous ai moi
même envoyer vos vidéos de chez vous
pendant le confinement vous pouvez
toujours envoyer vous à l'adresse qui
affiche ici amour @ monsieur gros point
fr il va falloir tout de suite là
millions du jour salue monsieur ouvreur
mois cet homme j'ai 14 ans je suis très
jeune et personnellement le confinement
ça se passe avec les jeux vidéo et le
travail donc les yeux c'est super
important au niveau là je joue une bonne
partie de la journée et je suis un
appartement dont je peux pas sortir mais
voilà rien de très compliqué et la
deuxième chose c'est que le plus gros
problème du recrutement pour moi c'est
que je peux pas aller je préfère pour
couper les cheveux donc c'est un des
plus gros problèmes
voilà donc c'est pas trop ce qu'on fait
à temps parce que personnellement moi je
joue et je m'ennuie pas vraiment je suis
plutôt en profite et voilà donc c'est
vraiment mon rêve
le confinement selon m merci pour cette
vidéo on va maintenant aller faire un
petit tour du côté de honor fxpro pour
voir quelles sont les différences avec
les honneurs fx qui vous faisait très
très rapidement côté de la boîte parce
que pas grand chose à raconter vous avez
effectivement le petit orientation
professionnelle sinon c'est sensiblement
la même chose
ce qui est surtout intéressant c'est le
smartphone en lui même et surtout
vraiment le coup
à retenir un des points forts c'est
qu'ici vous n'avez plus de capteur
d'empreintes digitales
vous avez donc un dos qui est
complètement libéré le capteur
d'empreintes digitales a fait son
apparition ici sur la tranche sur le
côté vous prenez votre smartphone vous
posez votre doigt il déverrouille
extrêmement rapide réactif et ça c'est
drôlement bien on trouve toujours les
petits boutons ici pour entrer tout le
reste c'est la même chose le haut
parleur l'usbc pour vidal recharger la
prise jack
on a toujours un écran de 6,59 pouces
ltps c'est du full hd + cic du lcd 2340
par 1080 pixels à 30 salle de france
pixels par pouces un écran qui certifie
et lutter contre la lumière bleue il ya
une seule différence je sais pas si
c'est vrai en tout cas ça c'est drôle
parce que il annonce que l'écran du haut
d'un fixe préoccupe 92% de la face avant
alors que sur l'honneur 9,6 il occupait
91% de la face avant
à mon avis c'est joue vraiment à pas
grand chose concernant la partie audio
c'est toujours la même chose vous avez
votre haut parleur mono qui se situe là
qui vous délivre un son très médium
s'est pas complètement extraordinaire
pour augmenter l'expérience une fois de
plus comme je dis sur l'honneur ne fixe
faut passer par la prise jack qui vient
se loger là et qui va permettre d'avoir
une meilleure expérience fille dix
modèles professionnels du modèle booster
dit modèle plus performant ici on n'a
pas un cuir in 710 f
on a un qui rime 810 c'est un des socles
de silicone qui est gravé en 7
nanomètres vous avez non pas 4 gigas de
ram mais si giga de ram c'est toujours
de la lpddr2 4x vous n'avez non pas 128
gia de stockage vous avez 256 giga de
stockage c'est toujours de lui fs 2.1
que vous pouvez monter grâce à une carte
micro sd jusqu'à 512 giga de stockage et
vous avez le gpu turbo 3.0 et vous avez
toujours en refroidissement liquide
vous avez donc avoir un smartphone qui
va être plus fluide et plus rapide en
termes d'utilisation c'est plutôt pas
mal
je les fais un petit badge mac seront
autour il ya le score de 300 5427 ce qui
vient de positionner la 42ème position
juste en dessous du galaxy note 9 et au
dessus du lg g7 think you la différence
kirin 710 f et kirin 810 vous allez
vraiment la sentir sur l'utilisation
globale de votre smartphone vous allez
pouvoir faire tourner des jeux plus
performant des jeux plus puissant c'est
cet aspect là du côté multimédia que
vous apportera plus de puissance ça me
permettra d'aller un peu plus loin en
terme d'autonomie que ce que vous aviez
sur le au turn fixe mais surtout ça vous
apprendra aussi plus de choses en terme
de photos et notamment au niveau de la
stabilisation vidéo mais ça je voulais
taille en quelques instants on a
toujours
une batterie de 4 millions terreur on a
toujours le même bloc de charge de 10
watts ça va pas changer très vite faut
vous armer de patience maintenant il ya
un poids qui change et qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est que sur le honor ne
fixe professionnel vous n'avez pas de
pelé store au nord fait partie du même
groupe que huawei et vous connaissez
l'histoire avec huawei qui aujourd'hui
peut plus utiliser les services de
google et qui appelait choix de toute
façon de façon définitive de ne plus
faire machine arrière même si on avait
la possibilité aujourd'hui huawei et du
coup au nord travail les hms les huawei
'mobile' service ce qui fait que là
dessus
vous n'avez pas catalogue d'applications
google vous avez le catalogue
d'applications de huawei qui s'appelle
la galerie j'ai fait une vidéo là d'ssus
d'un vitaly l'a visionné pour savoir
comment fonctionne la galerie comme ont
apporté les applications de votre ancien
smartphone sans votre nouveau smartphone
de huawei ou deux au nord
comment avoir vos contacts vous explique
tout ça dans cette vidéo allez faire un
petit tour comme ça vous saurez
exactement tout par contre ça veut dire
que si vous utilisez des services comme
google authenticator fournir vous
identifier sur des sites et bien vous ne
pouvez plus le faire il faut donc
vraiment faire un choix si vous voulez
un aux normes fixées vous voulez
utiliser les services google il faut
aller sur le online fixe si vous n'avez
pas réellement besoin des services
google et si ce que vous propose vous
voyez vous convient il faut aller sur le
honor daffix pro qui sera plus
performant sur la version que j'ai
actuellement hors cee hui 9.0.1 qui
tourne sur un android 9 la partie caméra
ne change pas non plus mais toujours
votre caméra de 48 mégapixels trouvera f
1.8 ici vous avez toujours votre
ultra-grand-angle qui situe la 8
mégapixels couvre f 2.4 que vous avez
toujours votre caméra de 2 mégapixels
tour f 2.4 qui est là pour la profondeur
de champ pour les faits évoqués pour le
mode portrait c'est la même
configuration la seule chose qu'il a
bien changé c'est comme vous avez plus
de performance grâce à votre terrine 810
et bien vous allez pouvoir faire un peu
plus de choses et vous avez ici votre
caméra pop up de 16 mégapixels tout bref
2.2 c'est exactement la même que celle
d'honneur de fix qu'on n'est pas ici sur
un smartphone extrêmement performant et
vous n'allez pas non plus à voir des
photos de dingue
par contre je trouve que dans l'ensemble
le travail qui est fait rend plutôt bien
je vous le montrer dans quelques
instants
alors que sur le au nord 9 fixe vous
pouviez avoir une vidéo stabiliser 720p
c'est à dire en hd ici vous allez montez
vous allez passer en 1080p
à lire en full hd à 30 images par
seconde pas en 60 images par seconde non
non non non non en 30 images par seconde
par contre ici n'aura absolument pas
quatre cas qui dit processeur plus
puissant d'idées photo amélioré et
notamment grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle et notamment sur la photo
de nuit
voilà quelques photos prises avec le
honor 9,6 procamera principal je peux le
rendu
l'allemand est pas mal la colorimétrie
tasse est juste on a bien l'aider talent
un boulot qui est plutôt bien fait qui
vous sort une photo en 12 mégapixels et
non pas ici en 48 mégapixels les
différences de colorimétrie par contre
avec ultra grand-angle qui va saturer
davantage les couleurs sont beaucoup
moins belle je suis pas extrêmement fans
mais bon si vous voulez les ultra
grand-angle pourquoi pas vous venez zoom
et même le x 2 franchement fait bien
apte à pouvoir compter sur un zoom
numérique est bon si on revient trop se
rapprocher enfin glisse tout de suite ya
beaucoup de bruit c'est pas terrible ça
lisse canada principal l'ultra grand
temps une fois de plus à saturation
n'est pas terrible on se rapproche et
voyez jusqu'au x 10 bon voilà c'est pas
complètement dingue caméra principale
ultra-grand-angle la banque où c'est
presque un peu mieux et on vient où mes
os x 2 et jusqu'en phase iib soyez pas
stabilisation c'est pas terrible
l'alakrana la principale fait vraiment
bien son boulot on à contre-jour voyez
bien l'arbre vous voyez bien tous les
détails voyez bienne mur il n'y a pas de
zone dont tout est pas créé mandat les
détails de tous les côtés vraiment l'a48
mégapixels travail extrêmement bien sur
la feuille la regardez là vous avez tous
les détails les détails et sierre
déconvenue de suite on perd un peu en
qualité mais globalement le rendu est
vraiment bien ultra-grand-angle bourse a
fait le boulot la chaude lumière est
plutôt bonnes ne s'est pas complètement
dingue on vient se rapprocher x 2 ça va
à peu près dès qu'on s'approche beaucoup
trop petite une fois de plus le bourg
une caméra principale ultra-grand-angle
fois deux fois dix regarder la caméra
principale c'est vraiment super bien
fait ultra grand-angle pas terrible et
leurs points n'est pas fait dessus fois
deux fois dix cars des mois sa caméra
principale c'est vraiment bien
ultra grand-angle pas terrible x 2 bon
voila c passable fois dit c'est pas beau
la caméra de celle fille fait le taf
j'avais pas vu que j'avais la peau aussi
celle du monde 2 est une catastrophe
mais ils ont globalement ça va alors
j'ai pris des photos en conditions de
faible luminosité il n'y a pas de
lumière dont le studio est bien le rendu
quand même pas mal vous avez une expo
longue de cinq secondes vous avez une
compensation du mouvement grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle ça vous
évite donc d'avoir une image trop foot
et c'est un dingue mais malgré tout le
rendu est quand même plutôt pas horrible
vu que ça aurait pu être
on refait exactement la même chose là ça
va beaucoup mieux ça bien compenser le
mouvement il vous assure qu'à quasiment
pas de lumière dans la pièce je change
d'endroit toujours les mêmes conditions
de lumière dans la pièce et là il ya un
peu plus de mal le mode portrait par
contre je trouve pas exceptionnel il
arrive par endroits bien des tours et à
d'autres moments c'est pas terrible
comme là il ya une différence entre le
modèle normal et le modèle professionnel
c'est que ce modèle normal vous aviez dû
bluetooth 4 points 2 ici vous avez du
bluetooth 5.0 bien évidemment sur
smartphone qui est 4g ici pas de 5 g
c'est normal il ya du nmc il a toutes
les qualités du honor ne fixe mais en
allant plus loin puisque oui c'est un
modèle professionnel qu'est ce qu'il
faut retenir que ceux au nord 9 x pro
est un modèle amélioré évolué du oud en
afrique sorti l'année dernière et qui
notamment permettra d'aller plus loin
surtout sur les usages multimédias comme
vous avez un grand écran des guerres
sans absolument aucune encore aucun
poisson et que vous avez une caméra pop
up vous n'avez pas certification ip68
c'était vrai avec le dans le fixe à
l'est toujours avec le nord date ex pros
néanmoins pour le côté immersif le côté
divertissement je trouve ça vraiment
bien vous allez aller plus loin en
termes de puissance vous aller plus loin
en termes de jeu vous pourrez donc faire
tourner des jeux un peu plus gourmand un
peu plus gourmand pas non plus s'affoler
ici pas de pelé store donc pas
d'application dedans que les stones ya
quand même beaucoup de jeu dans la
galerie va y avoir de plus en plus dans
les temps à venir ça il faut vraiment
venir faire votre choix pas le faire à
votre place plextor avec galerie ça
c'est à vous de voir quelle le catalogue
d'applications qui vous ira est que vous
ne souffrirez de l'absence de google
oui ou non d'ailleurs des firmes à vous
en bas en commentaire est ce que vous
pourriez vous passer les services google
pour utiliser les services de huawei est
ce que pour vous c'est inconcevable de
ne pas utiliser ce avec google ils
voulaient faut absolument marquer le
mois en bas ton commentaire sur mu barça
le deuxième usage de ce smartphone c'est
la partie photo on a les indispensables
la caméra principale fait vraiment la
faire l' ultra grand-angle suis pas
toujours hyper hyper fan ça fera halte à
ça dépendra bien évidemment des
conditions la lumière vous allez avoir à
l'extérieur
le mode portrait moi je m'en serais
passé à côté de ça c'est un smartphone
que je trouve plutôt pas mal bien
évidemment toujours dans son
positionnement tarifaire 249 euros et
d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse vous a
mis un lien en bas dans la description
est ce que vous aimez le dos de ce
smartphone avec cette petite croix en x
je trouve ça vraiment sympa mark et moi
tout ça on va en comment 4 à 1 on se
retrouve dès demain pour continuer à
parler texte en masse pour bisou bisou
le bisou ayotte plus fort
voilà des bisous à des mannequins
[Musique]